over the last 2 years we've are fully in
the process of the tiktock ification of
all social could have 19 followers on
LinkedIn tomorrow and decide it wants to
go and the first post could get a
million views if the post itself was
good okay this video got 4 million views
organically on Instagram Tik Tok YouTube
shorts let me now retake that video and
make it much more hard-hitting I'm going
to put a banner at the bottom that says
order now discount this let me change
the copy so taking the viral creative
and turning into an ad the viral
creative is building brand the ad is
building performance we call this brand
forance taking something that's gone
well organically and turning it into a
conversion a ticket selling
ad